[موسيقى]
ونحييكم مشاهدينا من جديد ده عرايس وزراء
المجار فيكتور هربان لاعاده النظر في
عقوبه المفروضه على روسيا دائما تصريح
الرئيس الفرنسي ماكرون الذي ذكر فيه بان
اوروبا والولايات المتحده تشاركان في
النزاع الاوكراني باسمي نفس المبادئ ولكن
ثمن الذي يتم دفعه ليس هو نفسه على جانبي
المحيط الاطلسي وقال اوربن عبر صفحته على
تويتر رئيس مكرونه حق ثمن حرب روسيا
واوكرانيا ليست هي نفسها على جانبي
الاطلسي واضاف اذا اردنا ان تبقى الصناعات
الاوروبيه على قيد الحياه فيجب علينا حل
ازمه الطاقه وبسرعه متابعا حان الوقت
لاعاده التفكير في هذه العقوبات
هناك هذا الموضوع مع ضيوفنا من كيان فولو
ديمير شوماكو
من باريس الكاتبه الصحفيه هدى ابراهيم
اهلا بكم الكريمين
اسمحوا لي ان ابدا من باريس معك يا سيد
هدى سيد هدى في الواقع المجر تتحرك
والمجر الرسميه كذلك تصرح
تحدثت عن انه يجب مراجعه العقوبات بالاكثر
من ذلك يبدو بان المجال رفعت فيتو هذه
العقوبات بمعنى انها قد تمنع الاتحاد
الاوروبي من تزويد اوكرانيا همم كذلك ليس
في ما يخص العقوبات هي نقشت العقوبات لكن
فيما يخص مساعدات اوكرانيا وكانها رفعت
فيتو لعدم تزويد اوكرانيا بالمساعده
اللازمه هل
تحرك يمكن ان يضر بوحده اوروبا في موضوع
مساعده كاف
هذا الموضوع ليس جديد المجر منذ البدايه
تتخذ موقفا ااه مختلفا وهي اليوم تجاهر
اكثر فاكثر بهذا الموقف نعم الاتحاد
الاوروبي لا يتكلم بصوت واحد بخصوص الحرب
الاوكرانيه الروسيه
وهناك مواقف لعدد من الدول
تتضارب احيانا وربما المجر هي الصوت
الاعلى بخصوص العقوبات او بخصوص تزويد
اوكرانيا بالاسلحه او مختلف المساعدات نعم
الاقي احد الاوروبي همم هناك خلافات وهذه
الخلافات نحن نرى انها تتزايد مع مرور
الوقت تؤثر على المساعدات وقد اثر على همم
تؤثر على العقوبات باختصار سيده تعتقدين
ان اعمل يعني الحقيقه انا مساله العقوبات
تاخذ الكثير الكثير من النقاش هنا ونحن
راينا امس يعني منذ فتره ان البنك الدولي
انبائنا بان الاقتصاد الروسي سينهار
بالنسبه ل 30% وهو اليوم يعود ويحدثنا بان
ذلك يقصر على ثلاثه او اربعه بالمئه اذا
المساله تتعرض للكثير من الشكوك وللكثير
من النقاشات ولا احد يملك حقيقه ما سيحصل
غدا بالنسبه لهذا العقوبات سيد شو ماكوث
ما رايك في موقف المجر هو موقف قديم ولكن
يتصاعد شيئا فشيئا ويمكن ان يلقيه بطلاله
على العقوبات على روسيا وعلى المساعدات
على كاف
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
تحياتي
موقف المؤشر وهو معروف
كمان خلال هذه ايام
هو اعلن بان الماجر لهم تقادم الصاعده
العسكريه لاوكرانيا وخاصه حول تدريب
الجنود الاوكرانيا
خليفه
لروسيا في كل مجلاته يعني كمان معروفه من
خلال تقريبا منذ اسبوع
تقديم الموساعده ماليه مالي اوكرانيا التي
سوف تقدم بسرعه ما اتحاد الاوروبي شيء
يعني بصفه عامه
[موسيقى]
التي تصرح بامكانيه تعديل العقوبات او على
الاقل محاوله مناقشه من جديد مكروم كذلك
سيد شوماكو تصريح قوي لرئيس الفرنسي قد
ياخذ الاتحاد الاوروبي باتجاه هنغير لمكان
عليه قبل
ماكرون كمان معروفين تذكري في بدايه حرب
وصيه المكرون وهو كان موالي بشكل كبير
لروسيا الان تحت الضغط
كبيره كماليه وكمان عسكريه همم من من
فرنسا ولكن احيانا موجود لتصريحات بصراحه
بالنسبه
حول الوضع همم في اوكرانيا يحاول يحارب
بين روسيا بين اوكرانيا يعني انه واحد انه
اقتصادي انا ادركه بان له فرنسا على فرنسا
موجوده داخل كبير يعني
انا لا ادركه همم مكرونه لان نحن ندركه
هو داخل في في فتره الازمات وهذا الجيتار
هذا القطاع ولكن حليفكم الفرنسي كذلك وضع
همم في الميزان مقاربه بينه وبين واشطن
السيده هدى مكرون لم يتحدث فقط على
امكانيه مراجعه هذه العقوبات او المحا
اليها هو تحدث عن انه تداعيات هذه الحرب
اثقل على اوروبا منها على امريكا وكانه
اراد التوجيه رساله للاوروبيين وكذلك
لواشنطن باننا نتحمل مسؤوليات اكبر
لكن هذا هو الواقع يعني همم اوروبا هي
التي تتحمل هذه الحرب وليس الولايات
المتحده التي تدفع بالمال وتدفع بحلفائها
للوقوف الى جانب اوكرانيا لكن الشعوب
الاوروبيه من المانيا الى فرنسا الى
ايطاليا الى اسبانيا الى غيرها من البلدان
هي التي تدفع الثمن القوي وحين يتم
الاعلام في فرنسا انه كان قريبا سيتم قطع
الكهرباء عن المنازل فهذا يشكل معاناه
الشعب الفرنسي لا يعاني مثلها الشعب
الامريكي فضلا عن ذلك هناك مساله اقتصاديه
ومشكله اقتصاديه كبيره بين الولايات
المتحده وبين فرنسا بخصوص المصانع وتصدير
همم
الحاجيات الامريكيه في العالم وهذه النقطه
كانت شكلت خلافا كبيرا بين الرئيسين
الفرنسي والامريكي واعتقد ان التصريح
الفرنسي ايضا يلعب في هذا الاتجاه ويلعب
في هذا
مضمار
حتى حتى امريكا صحيح ولكن حتى افهم منك
يعني هل يمكن ان تؤثر على موقف فرنسا لانك
منذ قليل تحدثت عن امكانيه همم قطع
الكهرباء على المنازل هي هو بدا قطع
الكهرباء على الشركات مثلا من المتابعه
دعوات حتى لما وقع تواصل الاجتماعي الناس
في مكاتبهم بمعاطفهم في فرنسا فهذا الوضع
هل يمكن ان يغير من موقف مكراته هذه الحرب
لا اعتقد راهما سيغير جذريا لكن هناك كما
لمسنا تغيير على مستوى التصريحات وهذه
رسائل همم ترسل الى الولايات المتحده اولا
همم قبل غيرها لان العلاقه يعني من خلال
زياره مكروه الى الولايات المتحده لمس
الاشياء
ولا اعتقد انه حصل على ما كان يبتغيه في
كثير من الامور الاقتصاديه لذلك فهذه
التصريحات تاتي اللي هي تلفت همم النظر
الامريكي الى ان في اوروبا هي فعلا يدفع
الثمن الاغلى في هذا الحرب خاصه اذا ما
استمرت وهذه الحرب مرشحه للاستمرار لفتره
طويله كما يعلم الجميع هي لن تنتهي في
الصيف المقبل هي حرب ستستمر الا اذا كان
صارت مفاجات سيده الا اذا كان فتح الباب
للمفاوضات لانه هناك تصريحات بخصوص
المفاوضات ولكن كل جانب يرمي الكره في
ملعب الجانب الاخر ويقول همم شروط اا لا
انا لا نجلس همم على همم مبدا شرط فخلينا
نتابع اولا لنفهم كيف سيكون الموضوع ولك
سيد شوماكوف همم من يتحمل مسؤوليه هذه
الخلافات الاوروبيه البعض يقول واشنطن ما
رايك
تعاني من ازمات الان في علمنا مواصله اكيد
بصفه عامه ان الروس هي خلقت هذه الازمه
الازمات مختلفه عندما هي هجمت غادرا على
اوك يعني كما نحن ناشد للاسف شديد في
اتحاد اوروبي شيله لا يوجد التوحيد همم
حول حول كان يا حول الله حرب يعني
اخف مثلا لو الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
عاملات شركات الفرنسيه كما تعامل شركاتها
المحليه لو اا واشنطن باعت الغاز لفرنسا
كما بعثه للداخل الامريكي فالبعض كذلك
اقترح انيقه استفهام على تعامل مواطن مع
هذه الازمه
بصراحه بصفه عامه موجوده غير تفاهم ليس
فقط بين فرنسا وامريكا وكما ينحرق بين
المانيا
امريكا
قبل نحن دخلنا في في العصر العظمات
اخر من ضروري
يعني وكانهم يستحسنوا مثل هكذا همم تطورات
همم حتى همم
يذوقه من ماذا يعني حتى على الاقل اوروبا
تنتبه الى ان هناك تدعيات قادره ان تنسحب
على كل اوروبا لا اعلم هذا ما فهمت من
كلامك استاذه هدى هل تعتقدين بان ضيفي
يخفف من الازمه بين واشنطن وباريس حتى وان
كانت صور جميله تبعنا زياره ماكرون وصور
ايجابيه جدا ولكن خلف الابواب المغلقه
لبعض يتحدث عن ازمات حاده
نعم هناك ازمات حاده خاصه وان بريطانيا
مثلا التي خرجت من الاتحاد الاوروبي تعيش
الازمه التي تعرفون هناك من يبكي اليوم في
شوارع بريطانيا بسبب الازمه الاقتصاديه
بسبب الكساد الاقتصادي بسبب انعكاسات هذه
الحرب على اقتصاد البلاد في فرنسا الوضع
ليس بافضل كثيرا في بلدان الاتحاد
الاوروبي هناك تضخم كبير جدا هناك مشاكل
كثيره جدا يعيشها الاقتصاد وامريكا كما
العاده بعيده عن كل هذا الوضع ولا تعاني
هذه المعاني
فقط
اوروبا او انها كانت تفكر في مصلحته ذاتيه
بغض النظر عن كيف ستتلقى اوروبا او كيف
ستعايش مع هذه الازمه
يعني الموضوع هنا معقد جدا هناك من يعتقد
بان الولايات المتحده نعم قصدت الى ضرب
الاتحاد الاوروبي والتوجيه ضربه لي
الاتحاد الاوروبي لكي تضعفه في مواجهه هذه
الحرب وهنا كمان يعتقد ان الامر
يختلف عن ذلك لكن الاعتقاد السائد في
اوساط فرنسيه كثيره وخاصه لدى اليسار
الفرنسي هو هذا يعني خروج بريطانيا من
الاتحاد الاوروبي في فتره سبقت هذه الحرب
كان نوعا ما بالتنسيق مع الولايات المتحده
والولايات المتحده ليست بعيده عن ما يجري
اليوم اقله لكونها يعني لا تكترس لما يجري
في اوروبا ولا تقدم المساعدات الكافيه او
الدعم الكافي او لا تسعى فعليا الى
مفاوضات همم تحدثت عنها قبل قليل لانها
هذه الحرب يعني اوكرانيا لو كانت الولايات
المتحده تريد ان تنتهي هذه الحرب غدا سوف
تجلس اوكرانيا على الطاوله لانها هذه
الحرب هذا يعرف هذا
الطاوله مفوضه ولكن ان رؤي سيدنا روسيا
التي بدات حرب
روسيا التي خلقت هذه ازمه
اقتصاديه يعني
تفرض على اوكرانيا الجلوس الى طويله
المفاوضات
بصفه عامه
همم حتى من امريكا
مهم جدا يعني مفاوضات ليس على شروطه روسيه
ولكن عليها شروط اوكرانيه يعني لان شروط
روسيه هذا الاعتراف
ولذلك نحن نصلوا في حاله مفاوضات مع شروط
اوكرانيا اذا توتر العلاقات الاوروبيه
اوروبيه اكثر ف- اا صار تعديل للعقوبات
ومن جهه اخرى صار احد في المساعدات
الاوكرانيه
مين غار ومن نجاح مين امريكا اليوم علي
نصير طيب اوكرانيا سوف تحصل كل المساعدات
خاصه عسكريه المطلوبه ولكن مهم جدا كل
الحيوانات
خاصه الخلافات الاوروبيه الاوربيه